[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
ihren apparaten guten abend und herzlich
willkommen und schönen guten abend alles
wichtige vom sport hat norbert könig für
sie doch für bernischen bildschirm
wir beginnen mit einem urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts dass viele
menschen beschäftigt
urteil zur trias wie ärzte im ernstfall
auswählen sollen wenn sie retten muss
die politik künftig per gesetz regeln
memorial vor dem aus russlands
wichtigste menschenrechtsorganisation
wird gerichtlich verboten
[Musik]
straßenkunst und modernismus an der
memel kaunas in litauen ist europäische
kulturhauptstadt 20 22
wenn sie das hören zu und viele menschen
zusammen jetzt hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht unverzüglich
ein gesetz gefordert dass menschen mit
behinderungen nicht benachteiligt werden
dürfen wenn es zu einer trias kommen
sollte also wenn intensivstationen wegen
cupid 19 irgendwann so überlastet sein
sollten das entschieden werden muss wer
behandelt werden kann und wer nicht
dabei darf nicht diskriminiert werden
attacke berichtet
schwer krank auf der intensivstation und
dort keine hilfe kein beatmungsgerät zu
bekommen davor hat er angst konstantin
rausch fürchtet wegen seiner behinderung
im ernstfall sterben zu müssen schlicht
weil seine überlebenschancen als zu
gering eingeschätzt werden deshalb hat
er geklagt und heute gewonnen erreicht
dass es ein gesetz gibt muss das ihm
dass menschen mit behinderung schützt
aus unserer perspektive hat eben das
verfassungsgericht hat heute und sehr
viel last von den schultern genommen und
der gesellschaft als auch uns allen in
auftrag gegeben diese frage noch einmal
intensiv zu debattieren debattiert und
in einem gesetz festgehalten werden muss
jetzt die ärzte in notsituationen
entscheiden welches leben sie retten
wenn sie nicht alle retten können
aktuell orientieren sich ärzte dabei an
empfehlung von fachgesellschaften danach
ist einzig die überlebenschance
ausschlaggebend geschaut wird wie es der
gesundheitszustand wie gebrechlich ist
der patient und hat er schwere
vorerkrankung durch die seine chance zu
überleben gemindert ist und eben diese
aktuelle vorgehensweise reicht den
richterinnen und richtern des
bundesverfassungsgerichts
hier bei beratungen karlsruhe nicht sie
fordern gesetzliche regeln die
garantieren dass nicht diskriminiert
wird genau das freut auch mediziner die
sich mit der schwierigen frage oft
allein gelassen fühlen
ich habe mit einer ganzen reihe von
kollegen gesprochen alle wünschen sich
dass die verfassungsorgane
leitplanken vorgeben dass es belastbare
regeln gibt von daher ist das gutes
urteil
verantwortliche politiker haben sich
heute nur über den kurznachrichtendienst
twitter geäußert die schreibt der
bundesjustizminister marco buschmann das
erste ziel muss sein dass es erst gar
nicht zur trias kommt wenn aber doch
dann bedarf es klarer regeln die
menschen mit handicaps schutz vor
diskriminierung bieten die
bundesregierung wird dazu zügig einen
entwurf vorlegen wie der aussieht da
gibt das verfassungsgericht den
gesetzgeber einen großen spielraum klar
ist aber die vorgabe aus karlsruhe
der gesetzgeber muss unverzüglich
handeln
es muss schnellstmöglichst gehandelt
werden sagt also das verfassungsgericht
und dazu begrüße ich jetzt unsere
leiterin der rechts redaktion sehr
attacke war gut abends jetzt muss eine
ärztin ein arzt ja immer schnell
entscheiden in dem moment im ernstfall
wären sie rettet wenn nicht kann das
überhaupt ein gesetz gerecht entscheiden
vorher die grundlagen legen ganz
schwierig natürlich aber die
verfassungsrichter haben sehr deutlich
hinweise darauf gegeben wie es möglich
ist ein gesetz so auszugestalten dass
ärzte in diesem extrem situation
möglichst diskriminierungsfrei
entscheiden im zentrum stehen dass ärzte
immer die überlebens chance in der
konkreten situation beurteilen und da
haben sie auch noch mal sind sie konkret
gewonnen gesagt damit das gelingt sollte
ein sogenanntes mehr augen prinzip
vorgeschrieben werden sollte
vorgeschrieben werden dass ärzte wenn
sie über leben und tod entscheiden immer
kollegen hinzuziehen um sich zu beraten
und sie haben auch darauf hingewiesen
dass ärzte doch auch sich weiterbilden
das verpflichtend sein muss und all
diese vorgaben oder hinweise und ideen
die die verfassung ist dem gesetzgeber
mit auf den weg geben deuten darauf hin
dass sie bei der findung dieses urteils
doch darauf gestoßen dass es erhebliche
mängel auch in der praxis gibt real
macht ja vielen menschen angst jetzt ist
das ja aber schon einig alltag von
ärztinnen und ärzten das stimmt der
notfallmediziner kennen das die kommen
an einer unfallstelle
und da gibt es mehr verletzte als sie
behandeln können und dann priorisieren
sie jeden tag und schauen wer kommt in
den rettungshubschrauber werden den
krankenwagen dem es auch nicht mehr zu
helfen wer kann warten das heißt diese
form der priorisierung gibt es immer und
auch außerhalb der mit der pandemie aber
die mediziner sagen ganz klar sie sind
froh wenn sie auch für diese fälle klare
vorgaben kriegen um sich besser
orientieren zu können vielen dank für
diese einordnung sache tacke
und haben sie noch fragen zum trash
urteil an unsere rechtsexperten saar
attacke dann können sie sie ihr stellen
gleich ab 1930 bei zdf heute live in
unserer app oder auf den social media
kanälen
zu einem weiteren aufsehenerregenden
urteil in russland vom obersten
gerichtshof er hat angeordnet die
bekannteste menschenrechtsorganisation
des landes memorial aufzulösen
begründung laut gesetz ist die
organisation ein sogenannter
ausländische agent weil sie geld aus dem
ausland erhält
nun sollen die moral wiederholt gegen
gesetzliche auflagen verstoßen haben
seit ende der 80er jahre klärt memorial
über verbrechen des diktators stalin auf
und setzt sich für politische gefangene
ein für bekam
gerade mal drei verhandlungstage braucht
das gericht um das ende von russlands
ältester menschenrechtsorganisation zu
beschließen
schande rufen die zuschauer nach der
urteilsverkündung eine
starke institutionen der
zivilgesellschaft die ich mit begründete
ist jetzt vernichtet mit hilfe einer
geradezu unverschämten zynischen
demonstrativen verletzung der
rechtsstaatlichkeit wurde sie zerstört
offiziell wurden memorial verstöße gegen
das ausländische agenten gesetz
vorgeworfen doch in ihrem
schlussplädoyer macht die anklage
deutlich worum es im prozess eigentlich
ging die organisation verbreite ein
falsches bild der sowjetunion die
historiker von memorial haben an die
verbrechen der sowjetführung gegen das
eigene volk erinnert die geschichten der
millionen todesopfer gesammelt ihre
vergessenen gräber zu gedenkstätten
gemacht und so die unbequeme wahrheit
übers tal ins terrorregime ans licht
gebracht damit bereite sie den
nachkommen der sieger macht ein
schlechtes gewissen klagt der
generalstaatsanwalt heute prozess
beobachter sind sich einig wünschen
handel das ist zu 100 prozent eine
politische entscheidung und der kern
dieser politischen entscheidung bedeutet
einen weiteren schritt von einem
autoritären regime hin zu einem
totalitären
russland zeigt wieder einmal härte und
lässt vor dem gerichtsgebäude
unterstützer von memorial international
abführen
für veganer moskau welche signalwirkung
geht von dem urteil aus
das erste signal das hat eine russische
politologin so formuliert durch die
auflösung von memorial werde die
virtuelle mauer eingerissen zwischen den
verbrechen der stalin-zeit und dem
heutigen russland bestanden habe denn es
ist in dem prozess eben doch ziemlich
deutlich geworden dass die organisation
dadurch in ungnade gefallen ist dass sie
unermüdlich an diese verbrechen der
sowjetführung gegen das eigene volk
erinnert hat oder mit steht oben real im
genauen gegensatz zu der
geschichtsschreibung die der kreml gerne
verbreitet werden möchte haben möchte
und wonach an die sowjetunion vor allem
erinnert werden soll im zusammenhang an
den sieg über nazi-deutschland
das memorial sich außerdem für die
heutige zivilgesellschaft eingesetzt hat
das dürfte auch nicht zu mehr
beliebtheit im kreml geführt haben und
das ist dann auch schon das zweite
signal das von dem heutigen urteil von
der auflösung ausgeht wer sich in
russland heutzutage für menschenrechte
und für demokratie einsetzt dem droht
die liquidierung
vielen dank für begabt über das urteil
gegen memorial
zurück nach deutschland um gegen die
korona variante omikron gewappnet zu
sein gelten seit heute in allen
bundesländern die von bund und ländern
beschlossenen regeln geimpfte oder
genesene dürfen sich egal ob drinnen
oder draußen nur noch als gruppe von
maximal zehn personen treffen sind
ungeimpfte dabei ist vorgeschrieben ein
haushalt plus höchstens zwei personen
aus einem weiteren haushalt im
einzelhandel und in freizeit und
kultureinrichtungen gelten zweig oder
zweig plus klubs müssen jetzt ganz
schließen
gegen korona maßnahmen gab es wieder in
einigen städten proteste in bautzen
wurden dabei polizeikräfte mit böllern
und flaschen aus einer nicht
angemeldeten versammlung heraus
angegriffen
zwölf einsatzkräfte wurden verletzt
einsatzfahrzeuge beschädigt in mannheim
leisteten demonstrierende eines
verbotenen aufzuges widerstand gegen die
polizei vor dem rathaus erinnerten
hunderte gegen demonstrierende mit einer
menschenkette an die korona toten um ein
zeichen für solidarität zu setzen
nach weihnachten hat das impf tempo in
deutschland wieder zugelegt am montag
bekam fast eine halbe million menschen
eine impfdosis während der feiertage
wurde weniger getestet und weniger
gemeldet deswegen sind die aktuellen
corona zahlen möglicherweise nicht
vollständig das robert koch institut
registrierte
21.000 80 neue infektionen innerhalb
eines tages und 372 weitere todesfälle
die sieben tage inzidenz liegt bei 215 6
die zahl der komiker unfälle ist jetzt
auf 10.400 43 gestiegen das tagesplus
liegt bei 45 prozent
einen schweren verlauf von corona fällen
kann das medikament packs sowie tandem
in der vergangenen woche hat es der us
hersteller pfizer auf den markt gebracht
nun kauft die bundesregierung davon eine
million packungen
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
sagte mit ersten lieferungen werde noch
im kommenden monat gerechnet
im vergleich zu deutschland wird in
china rigoros gegen korona ausbrüche
vorgegangen so rigoros dass die ganze
million metropole tieren im lock down
ist wegen relativ weniger fälle heute
wurden aus der nordchinesischen stadt
175 neuinfektionen gemeldet aber china
verfolgt als einer der wenigen staaten
eine null kowitz strategie was das für
die menschen in china bedeutet zeigt ulf
röller
in den chinesischen sozialen medien
machen sie sich mut mit patriotischen
liedern seit tag und dürfen die bürger
von tieren ihre wohnung nicht verlassen
die angst vor corona geht um ich liebe
china singen sie
[Musik]
pianist komplett im locker und 13
millionen menschen die weder rein noch
raus dürfen die behörden versuchen panik
zu verhindern
wir haben genug lebensmittel auf lager
um die täglichen bedürfnisse der bürger
zu befriedigen
das chinesische staatsfernsehen zeigt
massentests elf millionen in nur acht
stunden vermelden die behörden stolz in
wenigen tagen hat es mehr als 800
infizierte gegeben das sind sehr viele
in einem land wie china das bei jedem
infizierten nervös wird und angst vor
einer belastung seines
gesundheitssystems hat
unsere ambulanzen sind immer verfügbar
wir haben einen shuttle service für
patienten der fährt sie dann ins
gartenhaus in wenigen wochen beginnen
die olympischen winterspiele in peking
der ausbruch zeigt die 0 kokot strategie
funktioniert nicht perfekt und nun gibt
es auch noch die ersten omikron fälle
das beunruhigt viele in china
peking versucht alles um die verbreitung
des virus einzudämmen
in ihr werden sie wohl noch eine weile
im lockdown leben müssen
bis jahresende sollten 40 prozent der
bevölkerung ein ländern geimpft sein das
war das ziel der
weltgesundheitsorganisation
und es wurde klar verfehlt
in rund der hälfte der 194
mitgliedsländer sind eben noch keine 40
prozent geimpft vor allem in afrika aber
auch im extrem dicht besiedelten
gazastreifen ist die situation
besorgniserregend
nur ein viertel ist geimpft omikron
angekommen und das gesundheitssystem
überlastet annafest hat sich vor ort ein
bild gemacht
unterwegs im süden von gaza in diesem
krankenhaus wurde im august vor einem
jahr der erste group 19 patient
behandelt in diesen tagen sdr á la carte
fast genauso besorgt wie damals die
omikron variante ist in gaza erstmals
offiziell nachgewiesen nun läuft die
zeit darum doch auf und drückte wir
haben große angst vor dieser welle und
der neuen variante wir fürchten dass wir
nicht standhalten können mit 50
intensivbetten ist sein krankenhaus
besser ausgerüstet als viele andere in
gaza aber auf der gofit station fehlt es
an allem schutzausrüstung kaum vorhanden
noch nicht einmal ffp zwei masten für
das personal die patienten aber sind
dankbar ich danke ihnen doktor tausend
dank armins mutter liegt hier die
80-jährige ist ungeimpft ihr zustand
kritisch der sauerstoffgehalt im blut
ist erneut abgefallen angst sich bei der
mutter anzustecken hat der sohn keine
schließlich habe er sich zweimal impfen
lassen
immer wenn ich ins zimmer gehe
desinfiziere ich meine hände ich habe
keine angst und alle paar stunden wissen
sie den boden sie tun ihr bestes doch ob
das beste ausreicht um omikron zu
stoppen daran zweifelte auch ein
hochrangiges mitglied der hamas ohne
eine externe intervention ohne
internationale hilfe für den
gesundheitssektor wird das ein problem
das könnte in einem desaster in einem
gesundheits desaster enden
der ehemalige gesundheitsminister warnt
das sei ein wettlauf gegen die zeit aber
einer der kaum zu gewinnen ist
russland und die usa wollen am 10 januar
in genf über den ukraine konflikt sowie
über atom waffenkontrolle beraten
zwei tage später sind gespräche zwischen
russland und der nato geplant russland
will eine nato mitgliedschaft der
ukraine verhindern und hat truppen an
der grenze zusammengezogen
die forderung wird von mehreren nato
mitgliedern zurückgewiesen
kulturhauptstadt europas mehr als 60
städte durften sich schon so nennen im
nächsten jahr kriegen drei weitere den
titel eine davon kaunas zweitgrößte
stadt litauens mit dem titel will man
raus aus dem schatten der hauptstadt
vilnius und rein in slim rampenlicht
sich präsentieren etwa die eigenwillige
modernistische architektur die
straßenkunst die ein lächeln zaubert
aber auch die geschichte kaunas an april
ein bisschen streetart und ganz viel
modernismus damit überrascht die
europäische kulturhauptstadt 20 22 in
der zeit zwischen den weltkriegen war
kaunas die hauptstadt litauens in kaum
einer anderen stadt der welt gibt es
deshalb so viele bauten aus dieser
epoche des pacific in diesen 20 jahren
haben die litauer ungefähr 6.000 gebäude
errichtet wunderschöne häuser die
zwanziger und dreißiger jahre waren ja
die zeit von artdeco modernismus
bauhauses und anbau hause
kaunas als ort steht aber auch für die
traumata des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
sowjetherrschaft deutsche besatzung
30.000 juden wurden opfer des holocaust
auch darüber wollen sie während des
kulturhauptstadtjahres
ins gespräch kommen
wir wollen darüber reden was als
nächstes kommt wir wollen aus der
geschichte lernen um es zu akzeptieren
und gemeinsam darüber zu sprechen welche
zukunft wir wollen
marina abramovic yoko ono auch große
namen sind in kaunas vertreten insgesamt
sind 4000 künstler mit dabei
das ist da so eine riesige kreative
energie in der stadt und ich hoffe das
ist dann nicht nur so für ein jahr
sondern auch für viele kommende jahr
waren
energie die sich dann auf besucher
übertragen soll kaunas an der memel
freut sich drauf
gut fünf wochen vor beginn der
olympischen winterspiele kann ein
deutscher ski rennläufer schmal sein
trip nach peking planen dank einer
hochgeschwindigkeits vorstellung in
bormio mit platz fünf hat dominik
schwaiger die qualifikationsnorm erfüllt
noch nie ist der 30 jährige athlet aus
schönau am königssee bei einer weltcup
abfahrt so weit vorne gelandet
mit nummer 27 ist das ein urschrei wert
denn die favoriten sind links dem ziel
zwei minuten vorher und 1000 meter höhe
beginnt die beste fahrt seiner karriere
auf der eisglatten stelvio piste wo er
schon einmal schwer gestürzt war und ab
der berüchtigten traverse rus dominik
schweiger immer schneller mit
höchsttempo 130 dem ziel entgegen der
30-jährige vom königssee wird völlig
überraschend fünfter
joseph ferstl verschenkt an der
schlüsselstelle ein top ergebnis wird
sechzehnter
dominik paris dagegen fährt die perfekte
linie zum triumph in der italienischen
heimat vor den schweizern odermatt und
hintermann sechsmal sieger in bormio das
ist rekord
weltcup-spitzenreiter karl geiger
erreicht platz zwei in der qualifikation
für das erste springen der
vierschanzentournee mit einem flug auf
127 einhalb meter muss sich geiger im
heimischen oberstdorf nur dem
japanischen mit-favoriten riu kobayashi
geschlagen geben olympiasieger andreas
bellinger ist als einziger deutscher
ausgeschieden
kleiner dämpfer für manchester united
und trainer ralf rangnick bei newcastle
united tabellenvorletzter der premier
league schafft sein team nur ein 1 1 und
hat damit aktuell sieben punkte zu wenig
für einen champions league platz
nach ausreden suchen ist nicht sein ding
dennoch warf rangnicks mannschaft war
die zweiwöchige corona bedingte
spielpause anzumerken bereits nach
sieben minuten geriet manchester united
gegen newcastle in rückstand das 1 0
durch aller maximal
nach dem seitenwechsel sollte ein ruck
durch die mannschaft gehen doch nur mit
ein bisschen glück gelangen den red
devils der ausgleich und zwar in der 71
minute durch cavani
manchester bleibt zwar unter rangnick
ungeschlagen ist in der tabelle aber auf
rang sieben zurückgefallen
dankeschön arbeit und jetzt haben wir
noch eine kleine geschichte fürs herz
für sie aus italien in bologna gab es
eine unerwartete unterbrechung des
jahresabschluss konzerte sind teatro
dose der dirigent ergriffen wild
entschlossen das wort und machte der
flötistin auf der bühne einen
heiratsantrag
nach einem kurzen moment peinlich
berührten zögerns gab es dann die
erhoffte antwort jubel für anna-maria
und matteo frisch verlobt
beim beta wird es rutschig in den
nächsten stunden und in der nacht gibt
es glatteis mehr dazu gleich von özden
terli claus kleber begrüßt sie um 21 45
zum heute-journal und morgen steht hier
barbara hahlweg tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter beständiger tiefer
luftdruck auf dem atlantik sorgt dafür
dass auf der vorderseite dieser tiefs
immer wieder warme luft zu uns geführt
wird das bleibt auch so und natürlich
kommt auch regen mit und der gefriert in
der nacht vor allem im nordosten
deutschlands hier also glatteis bis
morgen in die frühstunden ist das
möglich ansonsten viele wolken und regen
dazu vor allem im süden kräftiger wind
aus westlichen richtungen teils
stürmisch im norden dazu nebel tiefe
temperaturen minus 1 grad richtung
ostsee und 9 grad im südwesten
deutschlands morgen gibt es immer wieder
wolken mit regen die durchziehen
zwischendurch ist es aber auch mal
trocken nach osten hin auch aber die
wolken bestimmen das wettergeschehen und
das bei höchsten temperaturen von zwei
grad an der ostsee und 14 grad im
südwesten deutschlands mit geht es
weiter in den nächsten tagen donnerstag
bis 16 grad viel regen ja und nach osten
auch kompakte wolken 7 bis 16 grad die
höchsten werte und silvester ähnliche
temperaturen neujahr zumindest trocken
und etwas sonnenschein ein schöner abend